traveled to Durban from Johannesburg for
what she says is a once in a lifetime
opportunity we never thought that one
day as soon
corrugation of our King so we say long
live our King Long Live
is the ninth King to take the Zulu
Throne his position now officially
acknowledged our King
is indeed officially
the king of the Zulu Nation
a certificate of recognition by South
African president Sula ramaphosa is
likely to bring an end to a family feud
around his succession
I understand that history has chosen me
at this time
when the Zulu and other nations are
facing several challenges
among the challenges of poverty
unemployment
climate change disasters
economic meltdown
food insecurity
feminine disease
that do not only ravage our people but
also
our economies the king clad in
traditional Zulu attire differs from his
father who at his coronation more than
50 years ago was made to wear a western
suit by the apartheid government for
many this is a celebration of tradition
and identity
the coronation and the upkeep of the
Zulu Royal household May cost taxpayers
millions of dollars every year but for
those here this is a chance to celebrate
their culture and Little Else Matters it
is very important for us to be here so
that we can be
as we are the Young Warriors we
appreciate him so much we are lucky to
have such a king a humble King yeah like
King missiles
[Applause]
thousands have come out to witness the
event as Warriors sing song of Praise
prepare to protect the king
and maidens honor him the popular young
Monarch prepares to rule over a nation
whose approval cements his rule to also
Look to Him for guidance for a
prosperous social and economic future
for midamala Al Jazeera Durban